as we continue to follow the absolute
tragedy that is taking place in texas
with power outages
people without hot water people without
heat people struggling to get
food we talked yesterday about
republican texas governor ted cruz
flying off to cancun with his family to
hit the beach that was ted cruz's
approach
beto o'rourke former democratic senate
candidate and presidential candidate
um decided instead
to phone bank and call elderly folks to
see if they were okay but he also is
making some
very appropriate and very harsh comments
about texas leadership
actually going as far to say that texas
is approaching failed state
status beto o'rourke said first of all
so much of this was avoidable going back
to the deregulation of our electric grid
here in texas which has actually created
an incentive to not
weatherize or protect against these
events better o'rourke
absolutely right as we've told you
before in 2011 texas had power outage
issues
uh an extensive report was compiled
saying do these things to protect
yourselves in the future they weren't
done and it happened again
absolute negligence by republican
leaders in texas
but then better or going further and
saying the energy capital of north
america
cannot provide enough energy to warm and
power people's homes
we are nearing a failed state in texas
and it has nothing to do with god or
natural disasters it has everything to
do with those in positions of public
trust
who have failed us people have died in
texas and tens of thousands
are still in the dark and cold and you
would think
maybe they'll change their tune on going
it alone
and separating from federally managed
power grids
maybe they would change their tune on
climate change doesn't
really mean anything because as climate
science predicts
you have erratically hot and erratically
cold weather events
that are part of a broader shift in
climate often to the warmer but that
doesn't mean you don't have outrageously
cold or erratic snowstorms
in places that don't typically have them
and of course if you try to bring that
up
texas republicans will now hide behind
that tired old trope this is not the
time
to politicize a tragedy is what they
will say well
it also wasn't the time to politicize it
in 2011 when this happened and you got a
report saying hey here's what you should
do
uh and you did nothing about it so i'm
glad that beto o'rourke is saying these
things
i worry however that he is sort of
yelling into the void
because there are so many republican
texas officials ted cruz
former governor rick perry current
governor greg abbott
lieutenant governor dan patrick these
people don't seem willing or remotely
interested in seeing reason
let's hope let's hope that by monday we
have better news about the circumstances
for uh tens of thousands if not hundreds
of thousands or even at the sort of top
top level millions of texans that have
been affected by this
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and they will pair
you with a mattress that will be perfect
for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video